foreign
you say you don't support reparations
why not not everybody suffered equally I
mean when you go into slavery
it's more much more complex than are
white people were the oppressors and
black people were the victims
if you if you dissect it you will find
there were about
3700 free bikes who own twelve thousand
slaves
black slaves the question is
do the descendants of those free blacks
who own black slave do they pay
I'm Bob Woodson uh president and founder
of the Woodson Center a national
not-for-profit that helps low-income
people in 39 States uh to develop
solutions to the problems of poverty in
their community
and uh but I have been critical of those
who have been using that rich tradition
of civil rights
as a bludgeon against the values of this
country
and I really think that the whole issue
of of reparations is an extension of
that misuse of the rich Legacy of the
civil rights movement in my more cynical
self says that this is more about
uh the elections of
2024 then it's about you know
reparations from 1619.
um I think that the the whole issue
is a deflection
uh uh is it a reflection away from the
real problems and challenges facing
majorities of blacks around the country
they are the the whole narrative is
driven by what the colleague of mine
called
a small group of guilty whites those
seeking absolutions from crimes they
never committed and a group of of
entitled black so seeking absolutions
some injustice they never suffered
and and I really think this is the whole
issue as I said on Dr Phil is that it's
more complicated than whites are guilty
and blacks of victims there were 3 700
blacks to own uh free blacks along
thirteen thousand slaves well to vote
the descendants of those people paid
you have Native Americans on the on the
uh Trail of Tears going from Oklahoma
they had 3 000 slaves that they took on
that journey to Oklahoma well to the
descendants of those Native Americans
pray
uh covert and so there are there are a
lot of contradictions here it's such a
complicated who pays and who benefits
from it that and and that it it's really
a waste of time and energy but again I
think it's really a deflection of
against the real problems but it's
having lethal consequences for
low-income black communities
uh low-income black communities having a
9 11 every six months more blacks are
killed in one year by other blacks than
were killed in the 40 years by the clan
uh and so tell me how uh reparations
could address that critical crisis and
for then the advocates for for uh
reparations to posture that therefore
the only way that Black America can
benefit and be uplifted is for white
people to offer reparations
I mean what does that say about the
capacity of blacks to be agents of their
own uplift it says that and so in order
to to solve a problem you got to
properly diagnose it and reparations is
no answer
or and for the challenges facing large
numbers of blacks in these City it's
lethal to continue to direct attention
away from the critical problems and
challenges facing black and reparations
is a major distraction
17 on Mother's Day weekend 17 blacks in
two cities was shot by other blacks a 10
year old girl was riding home with her
family from the Mother's Day dinner and
she was shot and killed in a car tell me
how reparations would address this
crisis
and so it is important for us to look at
what what is a priority here and and
what are the solutions that we're
seeking and and a black America is in a
not only black America but all Americans
our children are in a moral and
spiritual crisis
I'm laughing because some people can't
even tell who their fathers are
today
let alone chase the ancestors back and
if they did
um
where were those ancestors slave holders
or were they slave uh Masters
or were they slaves
I mean there's the whole preoccupation
with the time and energy that we can
spend tracing our history or to be spent
and mending the healing the wounds that
are in our own community
for Black America I recommend a one-year
moratorium and talking about white
people at all
I think you in order to solve a problem
you have to first diagnose it most of
the wounds that are being uh the orgy of
self-destruction is going on within the
black community there's nothing white
people can do to change this orgy of
self-destruction either The Taking of
drugs or violence or despair or
Unemployment uh discrepancies in our
health habits and all all of these lists
of pathologies that exist
can only be changed by the people
suffering the problem
as long as blacks can stay in a state of
agitation and anger
and they are directed towards race as
the as the source of that Solutions
I think that they're willing to
sacrifice black bodies to get black
votes
with the president's numbers declining
they have to do something to keep the
black community in line and race is is a
sure strategy
because when somebody's in the into a
constant state of grievance and
agitation they're much more easier to
control you can do nothing constructive
to your interest when you're angry or
grieved you can't make love you can't
eat you can't sleep
but you can vote
it's a ploy
you know it's a guardian not
it's just keeping us all at each other's
throat and it's being used cynically by
people who really are trying to
undermine the fundamental values of this
nation
but they're doing this using
social justice for blacks as debate
and then they really turn on the very
values that enabled Black America to
achieve black Americans the great story
in Blackmore isn't that we suffered
under slavery and Jim Crow is how we
achieved great uh successes in the face
of that oppression